dead cause we back at it again
[Music]
this is really the fighter and the kid
come on baby first of all I want to take
a minute and I want I want you to take
me and this is I'm wearing green and I'm
wearing a beautiful
beige then it was at Land's End it might
be it may as well be when you get to
that age lands ends you're attracted to
Land's End well so Daddy figured out
that I could shop on Amazon and pay a
quarter of the price well never did that
yeah but you're not getting like certain
things on Amazon I mean well for my fish
tank yeah I hate to take it back to fish
tank yeah my fish tank yeah all Amazon
now is that right oh just I sent you a
video my puffer well I was gonna ask you
I'd send you a video I was asking about
you talking about the Puffs what talking
about the puff Puffs well where'd you
get the pause from store let me ask you
this question them salt water fish no
those freshwater Puffs there are
freshwater Puffs out there I didn't know
that I didn't either and then I walked
by you know the tiger when we go the
thing he's like Dad let's get this daddy
this and he keeps pulling out salt water
I'm like dude if they look crazy they're
salt ones yeah we have fresh yeah and it
was daddy this I'm like I'm not gonna
that looks like fresh water he goes down
there puffer fish yeah I'm like those
are puffers
puffers are freshwater yes yeah yeah I
go
they there's freshwater puffer fishing
because yeah they get size footballs now
though those are juveniles
are they poisoned because no I went
check check and I go cool will will they
fit in the tanks those are tiny ones
though super cute
to their chin look chitty kitty kitty
kitty oh I want to do that they're one
of the smartest fish too so when I we
just got them yesterday when I walk into
the tank this morning to feed them yeah
they'll they'll follow your finger they
they they're one of the rear fish
they're like dogs yeah you can touch
them well when I was in when I was in I
look at their teeth when I was the same
front teeth as you and me oh when I was
in Tahiti when I was in Tahiti I I uh
scuba dived and I snorkeled with uh salt
water puffer fish now my buddy who's a
professional diver
saw someone step on a Stone Fish in
Okinawa oh bad idea and die oh yeah he
had booties on but if the the so the
real professional guys if you're in
Okinawa you want you want felt they have
a like a half inch of felt under your
booty so nothing good through yes
that'll stop sea urchins that'll stop
stonefish this dude didn't and he walked
and he stepped on a stonefish and went
into cardiac arrest and died on them
like some off-white J's or something no
he was wearing just regular booties like
like water socks oh yeah yeah the ones
and they look just like
they look and sometimes they'll cover
themselves they look just like stones
and just cover themselves in sand and
then they got a little
do these no that's not how they do it
when you step on them oh when you step
I'm saying when they eat though they're
the ones that disguise right yeah let me
show you so when you stop yeah I'm gonna
send it to Chen when you when it's when
you step on them that you you have major
problems yeah but you see what I'm
saying bee they blend in so they look
like they're Coral or something like and
then the fish just go by yeah and the
fish's like oh cool that kind of looks
like a fish yep I know
that guy that guy has the same size big
toes man
yeah look at they're insane Queen
queensland's dad extreme react after
stepping on stonefish Australia no it's
so bad now you can buy those too now for
the salt water my puffer fish not
poisonous you can buy them you can buy
those oh yeah you can get most things oh
[ __ ] but the the new puffer fish they're
in my 40 gallon tank right now here's
the other thing about puffer fish you
can't put them with any other fish bee
they they can't you can't mix them with
any other fish they will attack their
Uber aggressive a puffer fish that cute
little thing yeah cute Puffs Uber
aggressive watch this this is the most
venomous fish in the world watch this
and that is the most venomous fish in
the world
[ __ ] dude didn't you just grab it like
that I guess if you go under fish have
13 dorsal spines which hold two Venom
sacks on each of them if you apply
pressure they will inject the Venom said
to be one of the most painful things you
can experience well they had those
lionfish who told me not to get yeah
I've seen a picture I'm like yeah get me
a lion joking yeah they ate everything
they're super those are also aggressive
but the the guy who runs the aquarium
that I go to off of Sherman Way there
yeah he was saying he's like man they
suck too because we'll try to give him a
tank sometimes even if you're far away
from them they might just scoot over and
he's like think of a bee sting but like
they give up the same Venom as the bee
sting if you say intensified he's like
it just doesn't stop he's like you know
bees like Sting you and that kind of
goes away he's like it just keeps going
I always had my son had a bearded dragon
I used to have to go buy
um crickets and and worms and I stopped
doing the Crickets because they stink so
you get sell them uh you give them worms
and my this gal I know I used to work
with she was an actress and she had
tarantulas and snake
I know and she picked up a bird spider
now they had a bird spider go ahead and
bring up a bird spider big ass spiders
uh they eat birds so it's the biggest
[ __ ] thing with Goliath bird eater
they're that big yes that's real and she
got bit right there so she got bit right
there it bit her right there but you
know what it was like a bee sting she
said really I know well sometimes they
don't inject Venom sometimes they're
just biting to well to get away like
like rattlesnakes they're not always
shooting Venom they're just doing a
defense mechanism right well I went to
the San Diego Zoo by the way shout out
to mic drop Comedy Club I [ __ ] love
that club so much that's this new club
in uh where's it at in San Diego it's
it's
um 50 minutes away from or 13 minutes
ago 13 minutes away from Gaslight and it
is I'm telling you man they are they
know what they're doing so Phoenix used
to run uh stand up live and same people
that run stand-up lives yeah well she
used to work there and now she's the
general manager she's amazing but dude
I'm telling you it was such a [ __ ]
amazing experience and the crowds were
incredible and how many does it see and
there's Dominic Cruz right there he came
oh Steve he was with you yep Stevie
showed up and I got to hang with Dominic
Cruz who I've been a fan of forever of
course how could you not be such a smart
[ __ ] dude and then I'm and then I'm
learning wrestling from his his
wrestling coach who's there teaching me
[ __ ] in the green room is hilarious oh
[ __ ] dude he did he did he showed me
some nasty [ __ ] he showed me like these
wrist blocks I was like oh my God [ __ ]
you're never gonna do by the way well
you never know if I I came up it's a
complete waste of time but also came up
with some [ __ ] for against did you ask
Dom like Brandon keeps giving me
endorses and stuff yes so I got some
[ __ ] I got I got let me just say this if
you and I go and we will go and we will
go I have a new sweater so not today we
will go it's on sandals and it's rain
but whatever we know but we know we're
gonna go we know that ultimately this is
going to happen again okay on down right
yeah now I'm sure it's gonna rain again
in La I'm gonna choke you out no no no
shut shut your stupid mouth shut your
stupid mouth because I have some tricks
and I and I understand some things I'm
wrestling and his wrestling coach now
Hold on shut your stupid mouth because
in the Green Room at mic drop Comedy
Club I put some [ __ ] arrows in
mcquiver oh yeah yeah yeah yeah well I'm
like a puffer fish are you poking Daddy
are you gonna get the poison really he
poking really now real quick just
hypothetically I'd say I locked the door
to your green room it was you and
Dominic Cruz right and someone said
who's gonna walk out of this room alive
I'm just hypothetically saying what
would happen now with the big old thick
puffer fish walk out of that green room
I like to think so you got Dominic with
a lot of [ __ ] tricks Legends and you
got Brian with a heart like a lion I got
two lion Hearts you know that do you
know I got two lion Hearts you don't
know oh you're like an earthworm
multiple Hearts yeah but I'm I gotta put
their Lionheart yeah but you build my
chest open don't say lying more like a
worm well you're probably like an
earthworm I'm gonna get to that
Earthworm Jim I'm gonna get to that but
Dominic and his wrestling coach show me
some [ __ ] if I get under hooks on you
understand this I got Alternatives okay
because you're gonna counter and I'm
gonna do something okay oh because you
think you've seen the whole Bishop
catalog well you think you're you think
you went through the whole catalog of B
I don't hey hey look at me 15 years
about your dumb catalog how about that
yeah hey yeah yeah Oh Donna Cruz hyped
you up does he give you a speech before
this I got [ __ ] dude because he showed
me [ __ ] and you're not gonna see it and
I'm gonna [ __ ] capitalize on it and
I'm gonna say his name when I capitalize
for you domain yep so just know that
when we tussle and we will I got an
answer okay cool just remember daddy
puffer fish now no I understand keep
poking me dude I understand you know
what's up about puffer fish they can be
pop
no yeah no they can be
huh but you know you can't do the puffer
fish what choke them out I'm not choking
a puffer no I'm not worried about
choking you out but do me a favor watch
your wrists and your ankles okay
it's me
no you can be
if we're in the room alone and the
lights are off he's here
that means Daddy's puffing up
well I will say this uh Dominic fights
at one three five and Dominic stepped in
at about one seven zero and I looked at
him and I went well you're bigger in the
neck shoulders and arms than I am and
that's what I realize is that I am as an
athlete and a man and this is okay it's
okay if you're liking me to a dog I'm
I'm just I'm just a regular mutt Oh no
you're saying is a little helper from
himself I don't have any pimple in me at
all no I'm a regular ribs I'm a
sweetheart I'm a nice potato nice doggy
you pet me your breath sucks well my
your nose is all dried oh but I'm little
I'm a mutt that you love Yeah your Poor
People's Dog I'm not gonna protect you
when the house gets broken into you're
gonna hide oh wow are you gonna lick the
[ __ ] burglars I'm gonna talk a big
game i bark I talk Brian talk you like
your Great Dane they look scary but not
that big not that big you're a puppy
Great Dane well yeah no I'm I'm a mutt
that's gonna bark a lot and then when
you come in I'm gonna go you guys want
to be friends oh you guys really kicked
down that door yeah you gotta know who
you are hey let's take a little break
buddy let's go take a break sometimes
you gotta take them now you and I don't
take a break from doing stand-up because
I'm in Tampa next Friday Saturday I'm in
Indiana one show Friday and one I'm
sorry two shows Friday two shows
Saturday that's next Friday Saturday
that's January 20th and 21st Tampa
Florida and you're going over the blue
the Blue Room in Springfield have you
been there I've not but I heard good
things before third and fourth yep
Friday Saturday only there and then
Naples Florida well dang I got four
dates in February cool February uh 16
through the 18th Naples Florida and then
Bakersfield one show only this will sell
good tickets right now bigger Fields
California Bakerfield California
February 23rd and then Brea right now is
just March 4th that's just the Saturday
because I might have to be comparing on
Friday and the third so right now buy
tickets for Saturday Brea California
Bray improv March 4th with special gifts
very special guests I like that take us
at thick boy.com or fatkz.com guys you
want to come to four
yeah if you are anywhere in Indiana I
don't care if you're in a state around
there run to the summit what else you
can do Fort Wayne what else is going on
you're gonna see Brian Cowan January
13th and 14th I got two shows in the
13th Packers aren't in the playoffs it's
a packer City it's a packer city they're
done they're done so you know what to do
come hang come hang we'll talk about
Aaron Rodgers after the show come check
out Brian's old balls Dania improv
January 19 2021 let's come see some of
that Edmonton Alberta well it's cool
it's cold the comic strip February 23rd
24th 25th that's going to be very cold
but I love Edmonton Nashville Tennessee
we're not here to talk about datesby
we're here to talk about a little
company
well look there's there's a thing called
bespoke post let me tell you what what
goes on with this I still have one of
their little whiskey glasses you open
the box it's a box of awesome yeah every
every unique item is hand curated from a
small business that you probably would
never have heard of I made great stuff
they got cozy Essentials to travel
must-haves cocktail kits all kinds of
things and it comes every single month's
box of awesome.com it's like a Christmas
every time it comes you never know what
you can get but you can take a quiz you
can take a quiz and I'll help you pick
the right box of awesome for you they
release a new box every month across a
ton of different categories each box is
valued around seventy dollars but you
only pay a fraction of that price plus
with each box of Awesomeness you're
supporting small businesses small
businesses
yeah dude 90 of everything that comes in
your box of awesome is from small up and
coming Brands it's free to sign up you
can skip a month or cancel anytime you
want you get 20 off I'm gonna give you
20 have your first monthly box when you
set up a box of awesome.com enter the
code fighter at checkout box of
awesome.com code finder for 20 off your
first box box of awesome.com code
fighter I believe that they sent us a
couple and I'm excited oh yeah I'm
excited box of awesome oh my God Brian
it's the Wild Card time in the NFL it's
wild card there's nothing better baby
nothing better you got defend you're the
the bills I've taken the bills all day
long are you oh daddy am I ever you have
the Chargers you got the Seahawks I'm
taking my La Chargers Chiefs aren't in
the wild card can you shut your yapper
right because they have a buy because
they're the best team in the league the
best team in the league so they're not
enough so they won't be in the Wild Card
right and neither are the Packers nope
but the Niners are who are my Dark Horse
to go but if I want to make money if I
want to make money you gotta use my
friends at draftking Sportsbook an
official sports betting partner of the
NFL kick off the road to Super Bowl 50
seven new customers can bet just five
dollars and get 200 and free bets
instantly plus all new and existing
customers and get a no sweat bet each
day of the Wild Card round this weekend
to replace any NFL bet on your choice
and if it loses you'll get free BET back
up to ten dollars action is so good why
bet NFL playoffs anywhere else how do
you do it you just download the
DraftKings Sportsbook app yeah I use the
code fighter and if you've got if you're
a new customer you can bet five dollars
on any NFL team and get 200 in free bets
instantly instantly only at draftking
Sportsbook with the code fighter minimum
age and eligibility restrictions apply C
show notes for details now let's get
back to the program as I get older I
start to realize now Dominic Cruz I
don't know if you know this there's the
the called the Mamba mentality you've
never met a more competitive person in
your own Brian you don't know a more
competitive person yeah than Dominic
Cruz well he will try and beat you at
every single thing
no we were talking and he practiced
before he's ready when he saw Kevin he's
in six five he'll beat the shot Kevin I
know that and he saw Kevin knows that
Kevin goes thank you for not killing me
yeah but Kevin
and took in his stature and in his mind
Kevin was like that's not a tall guy and
and Dominic said well when I saw your
boy
I I'm I kind of he said hi and he and I
he was a little bit like hey what's up
and I thought to myself how would I
fight this guy he was thinking about
that at all times at all times at all
times and by the way wants to fight
again
so he's Dominic is we had a long talk
about that we had a long time it should
have been Dom versus Frankie Edgar a
legend
damn that's what Frank said too he was
like that would have made sense remember
we had him on here yes and on the food
truck he's like that would have made
sense same size everything wow yeah same
size both at the end of their careers
both first ballot Hall of Famers yes Dom
you know one of the best analysts in the
game like such a mind for it I told him
I told him that too I go uh you know you
said how smart he is and how good he is
he was like are you making me blush but
he's a great he's one of my favorites
[ __ ] great guy just a great but
whatever it is be ready tic-tac-toe
chess no no he's gonna beat you get into
the airplane early he's going to try to
do whatever his entire life he's the
Michael Jordan you know Michael Jordan
like whatever you're playing yeah he's
that guy it's exhausting I can see I
love him but it's I'm not that guy I'm
like yeah you won cool dude yeah
well when you when I talked to him about
that too when you look at him he wasn't
gifted with Incredible athleticism he
was gifted with it with a mind the no
don't get it twisted he's a stupid out
freak athlete so that style you see now
yeah of the switch and the movement and
the hands yeah that's all dumb everyone
Cody garbage he's athletic dude athletic
but I wouldn't say I wouldn't say his
athletic as a guy like algeman Sterling
for example would you
he in his prime man like WC he's up
there what I mean you're talking about I
would think his brain is what got him I
think it's well I agree well the brain's
what made him the best 135 would ever do
it yes his body though like his
athleticism and competitive Drive which
goes to his brain
that dude is an outlier yes because
remember too even physically too in all
checks the box and everything you don't
become a champion like that without not
at his level like you don't become that
dominant of a champion without being an
outline yeah it's complete Savage
complete Savage Savage [ __ ] Savage
one of my favorite people in the game
yeah he's a great guy is his coach uh
who is his main Name Escapes Me was
[ __ ] a great guy too was it the coach
from Alliance yes got a big beard yes
um I'm gonna find out Craig you have oh
yeah because I got you in my Camp to get
ready for metronome with Gus Finn and
Dominican my boy Nick lamania shout out
to Nick he he was the one who set me up
with it and uh his name is Jeremy
um yeah Jeremy great guy he was your
eyes roommate in college
and he's a [ __ ] He's I guess he's a
hell of a wrestler man he's still if you
type in if you type in uh point is I
know a lot of [ __ ] now the point is I
have a lot of tricks so be respectful
when you when you when you when you
coach my p's and q's just be respectful
come correct don't come incorrect at me
cool we cool we cool bro because I'm I'm
a Dominic I'm a Dominic slash Jeremy
disciple now so come come correct don't
come incorrect you big guy you big boy
right you big boy you big boy come
correct because I'm not stepping back
I'm not a mutt that barks anymore
you're a tough guy well here's my thing
B what bro how tough do you think you
are ask me if you're this tough okay so
and I know we just hear me out here
before you chime in before you chime in
and give me your real opinion hear me
out here yeah so I was in Vegas good
friend of mine Zach Baggins right Ghost
Adventures guy big boy doing big things
yeah don't care about his physical
attributes so he goes you know he does
ghost adventures all that I text him I
said yo heading to Vegas would love to
see you he goes ah whatever he had
something coming up he goes maybe I'll
come to Saturday's show he goes you guys
should go to my haunted Museum I said is
there serial killer stuff he goes yep I
went say less me David Lucas his girl
and Jay are going to come he goes you
got it VIP tour VIP tour we go to that
hunting Museum
and Dave's like it's like a haunted
house I'm like no no like real [ __ ]
David like real [ __ ] dude like they're
not people are gonna jump out and scare
you like real [ __ ]
when I tell you I was scared shitless I
haven't slept right come on
Brian do I'm telling you dude David
Lucas halfway through the tour laughed
halfway through the tour was like I
don't do this anymore not because he was
bored because he was scared he got out
of there they they have this
they have this they call it the the
roots of evil and this lady who was in
um
this lady who was in the Holocaust and
she was the Jewish lady that she felt
like all the people that died during the
Holocaust they're like bodies and the
the the evil demons within that the
Nazis and all that that aren't these I
know just hear me out on these pieces so
they it's the most supposedly I have
evidence back this up it's the most
haunted artifact on the in the world
costs too much money they have this this
kind of book thing right
and it's but it's enclosed so when you
go buy it you just go buy it you see it
whatever
and then uh I was talking to Zach about
and even post Malone talked about in the
Rogan show so Zach uh post Malone you
know who he is right of course okay cool
thank God so he was in Vegas he's a fan
of Zach they get together that goes
that's closed but I could give you a
private tour and post Malone's like hell
yeah me and my boys are coming they go
you're not supposed to take the cover
off this thing
he takes the cover off and that's
exactly he's sitting stay in front of it
right there Jen which one the third one
down to the right what is it yeah no no
no go down dude so it's the only one
exactly yeah there you go that's it
right there
so that thing right there has all this
artifact so it's so haunted people
buried it want to get rid of it right
so it's so haunted so Zach thought it
was a good idea to take the cover off
and have post Malone touch it
since post Malone did that his bad luck
has been his the next day his plane
crashes on his way home he survived he
falls off stage at the concert his house
got robbed and he got a car accident
well this might be like the accident
it's all coincidence
ever the world went to [ __ ] except for
Rogan it was lucky for him yes but even
he had to hit such a zillion dollars
yeah that's true yeah actually it was
good it was good for him bad for
everybody else yeah for everybody that's
the whole room the whole world hey coven
hey I don't blame on you but you start
coping I might have hey was it leaked in
a lab or was it leak from JRE in
Woodland that's a good question I blew
that that one hell whistle I think that
they were because the virus was lodged
in the death whistle I blew it out and
it got out but be back back to that uh
that Horizon so you know my my things
serial killer my black belt and serial
killer you would like the Al Capone
thing because what Zach does and he's
like this is his Museum his Museum yeah
in Vegas in Vegas okay but the Museum's
actually in a house that supposedly
super haunted when I say haunted because
it was it used to be a Satanic ritual
site so there were kids and women were
murdered in the basement through a
satanic cult Jesus so that base went
home you go down there super haunted
well I won't get to that so he has all
this all these artifacts there
and he would tell the price of it
because it's all expensive but when you
get that like I said you'd like the Al
Capone thing because Al Capone they have
his carpet this is all legit stuff oh
it's all they they have all the the
pictures and then then it's uh signed by
uh when you buy like South bees
it's all signed but like okay
everything's authentic that's legit
you're going to Al Capone room they have
the only picture the actual picture from
his house Zach bought it in auction of
him and his son
and then they have his carpet where you
Pace back and forth and do whatever
deals and he had a cigar he put the
cigar drop in so it has all his burnt
whoa it's so cool so that's cool I don't
think Al Capone's haunted whatever but
the thing where it gets dicey is the
serial killer room which I was like oh
say less here we go so we go in the
serial killer room right
you walk in to your right is the actual
shirt that Richard Ramirez was wearing
during trials that black shirt and then
his notes to All His girls because he
had so many girls coming out from his
actual handwritten notes autographed wow
then to the left this is what I was like
this is so intense to the left is Ted
Bundy's mask that he would rape and
murder all the women in he would wear a
mask to get him his actual like ski mask
the actual mask the actual mask with his
gym bag that he used and there's like
all these like blood stains on the gym
bag with the tools he'd use the murder
the actual tools engine bag
I would I hate that although dude then
you keep going they have uh John Wayne
Gacy stuff they have Charles Manson's uh
remains he paid for all this they have
his teeth he had he got fake teeth
playing and he put uh Nazi signs on them
they have that sitting there and then
you go into the I was like this is so
intense but I wanted more time in there
but we have to hurry up you go to the
next room they have Dr kevorkian's Van
where he would you know assisted suicide
people in there that the van they
thought was destroyed all this stuff to
death Museum
but the tools for death and dude and
then you go in this other room this is
where you would been scared shitless
you're in this other room and I know my
serial killers and then Zach texts me
goes hey just give you a heads up the
the Kansas City butchers really intense
and then the basement is optional I
don't even go down there but have fun I
was just trying to scare us we walked in
the Kansas the Kansas City butcher uh
area
and I know my serial killers never heard
this guy I think it was like in the 80s
you know I heard him right I've never
heard of them
dude this psychopath this
sociopath would get young gay men and
they would torture them Zach's crazy ass
had the bed they were tortured on he had
the exact device he used to torture him
then had pictures on the wall of the
victims before they were killed yeah I
don't know oh it was why would you do
this like this oh so awesome but it was
so intense
the doctor could work and stuff so
you don't got to be a bad guy you look
more into them it it's controversial do
you know much about Kevorkian I really I
really went down a rabbit hole that
night I couldn't see myself I know
enough I've listened to interview I went
way far down it's interesting right I
think he's with the Kevorkian thing the
quality of life there are people that
have such a terrible life that he helped
with assistance like the like the
victims too like there's one kid he had
like horrible uh forget what the Lou
Gehrig's Disease were but he couldn't
talk anything and Kevorkian would you
know in order not to go to prison for
murder he'd have them on record saying
yeah okay why am I here did he go to
jail he didn't right eight years eight
years ago they finally got him yeah
eight years wow and then he got out
but that but that museum it's dude it's
fascinating [ __ ] fascinating if you're
into that stuff fascinating but the
basement where the basement where the
kids and the women were murdered and
with the satanic cult so
Jay was kind of down Jay scare that
stuff so you go down there it's pitch
dark and you get down there and actually
just I don't know when I think about
kids dying like satanic stuff I'm like
oh hell no so I told you I'm like go go
we turn back we run back upstairs the
lady because the private tour she goes
uh listen what am I supposed to do this
I'll go down there with you guys with a
light on I closed this place that night
by myself I go oh so you're not scared
to us yeah I'm terrified but I still do
it oh wow okay they're not paying you
enough she goes who are you telling so
we go down the basement and you get to
where they did the Satanic rituals dude
and they leave all the stuff there so
like they had it there's no bodies
nothing but so the pet was it the pente
is the pentagram the pentagrams there
the candles are there it the energy was
so dark dude oh I'm just like I I'm this
is too much for me I just can't well
Daddy hasn't hasn't slapped
I don't blame you haven't slept well
since I saw that yeah you can't go to
the dark sides like everything in life
is like what are you gonna what do you
choose to focus on the good or the dark
man good luck living in the dark like
that oh but if you like that stuff like
I am like I do like the serial killer
stuff like the artifacts and the Al
Capone stuff oh and then they had this
is interesting too that Sharon Tate's
wedding dress there
did I ever tell you like did I ever tell
you and then they then they also had you
tell me this and Jay was like um you
know Jay he likes to argue so he's like
arguing with the lady I'm like what are
you doing
they had so James Dean in that Porsche
he had a I figure what was a speech
report he died in that Porsche right
so a week prior to that Porsche he has a
meeting in Hollywood with this other
actor and the actor he pulls up at the
restaurant he goes to meet him he pulls
up at the restaurant an actor's like oh
it's a new car and James and he's like
yeah I just got it man and he explained
to him he's a Gearhead he's only like 24
20 26 when he died 26 Gearhead like
loved racing like would actually do
races and [ __ ] yeah so this was a car
back then and the guy they have him on
the video goes uh it was like a day
after James Dean's death he goes this
one's crazy I met him for dinner last
Thursday that night I told him before he
sat down and goes hey I don't like that
car man and James Dean's like what
that's a poor speaker he goes no no
there's nothing to do with the make and
model of the car that car I'm telling
you if you keep driving like you are and
the the vibe that I'm getting from that
car you're not gonna be around it you're
gonna die in that car and James Dean
laughed off she got his head cut off
right he lost I think he got to capture
he got really messed up here's what's
about that car
that car right they they um
the guy who was on the I think on the
the passenger in the car survived and
his race car driver he he drove the next
day in the race he died
he died
the person that transported the the
wreckage in that car driving it right in
the trailer yeah he died driving it
really he died the guy transporting the
car died so the car goes missing for I
don't know years is one of the most
sought after uh uh historical evidence
out there yeah no one knows where to
find it
they somehow Trace back to this lady's
garage and like I forget where somewhere
like up up north in uh California they
find parts of the car they don't happen
the rest of it
Zack Baggins I don't know how much uh
the trout channel is paying but this
dude has money he buys the actual axle
from the car he's like for the first
time I'm excited to tell you guys it's
all verified everything because those
axles have VIN numbers on them that's
the exact VIN number I came when we
found that they actually didn't find the
car
they can't find the car
there's the car is nowhere to be found
still to this day
um man isn't that [ __ ] interesting it's
interesting I just can't live in that
sort of Darkness
yeah I would tell you like I don't know
why I like it it's like is something
wrong with me like the serial killer
stuff I like that's what it is is that
so that a lot of times people that do
that it's you want to get closer to the
thing that horrifies you it's it's the
only way that you can kind of
contextualize it so why do I like like
I'll fall asleep to True Crime
information you want to know how their
mind works maybe because the world's so
dangerous and it makes no sense because
life is so hard right like an intense
like when you want to accomplish
something it like it's so difficult and
then you realize there's a guy like the
Idaho murderer that can come into your
house and kill the the thing you love
more than ending your child like you're
like wait what you just did that because
you were stalking them for like a month
before that and then you went and killed
them in their sleep and you know he he
went you that that cycle interrupted me
but you know that the more facts came
out the psychopath went to the visual of
the victims he showed up there at the
visual I'm sure I'm sure it's a visual
and then he also there's rumors the
visual what do you mean the vision
visual visual visual
I don't know but they have pictures of
him there though they think it's him
that's how psycho is and then also
there's a rumor forever that uh he was
in uh contact with the BTK killer
because he's still alive one of the
worst people I've ever [ __ ] do I
can't stand that guy killed kids
but there's rumors that he um was in
communication with him to help him with
the murders and the BTK killer came out
this is how bad this guy is BT K killer
came out was like I have nothing to do
with this guy I'm glad authorities
caught his ass
that's him right there dude
how crazy is that ah here's what else is
crazy he wants to be the guy that caused
all the problems here's what else is
crazy there's a whole like Facebook or
Reddit chat I think fit is a Facebook
chat on the murders of like they would
get tips and information they found out
he had a troll account and the FBI went
back and looked through it and that's
how they one of the ways they caught him
that he was getting out facts that they
didn't release to the public yet like he
gave out the murder weapon they're like
hold on who's this guy they looked more
into it and found out it was actually
him getting on there well he was also
here he left his sheet there with his
DNA oh so slot sloppy like like somebody
said he was a criminal
um uh justice major criminology
criminology major but but he was so
sloppy it was like amazing how much he
didn't learn well it was you can be a
criminology major but when it comes down
and your your drone's going you're
killing those kids like yeah dude yeah
he got off on it this isn't Dexter [ __ ]
like you're gonna make some mistakes you
know hard is to cut somebody and or cut
their
but like you know
um when you realize that there are
people like that that can that can
destroy everything that's good and they
do it because they get off on being
they're like artists of pain they're
artists of death like that's how they
express themselves it the only thing you
can do is figure out a way to get close
to it so you can at least put it into
your own context it's so traumatizing
you might be right well there's that
like with the killing because I mean
it's so [ __ ] terrible and tragic it
ruins families and lives I I don't the
the serial killer thing I know I'm drawn
to it because then on the other end of
that like really bad like trolls or
haters like just vindictive like really
nasty I I just I turn a blind eye
because I can't even understand but
that's the same idea to me to me with
that I don't understand it like and I
don't want to understand yeah I assume
they have their own issues that's why
they're directing the hate towards us or
to whoever I don't understand it it
because the same way I guess I
understand why that piece of [ __ ] in
Idaho killed those kids I don't
understand it because those kids did
nothing to him but also when it comes to
like me or you with me it's like hold on
you guys want to but you want basically
want me to live on the street with my
wife and children because I do free
podcasts and stand up well no you know
what I'm saying but to me but I can
understand well there are people and it
never works out like so so one of the
things that I'm going to tell you like a
story about this like so so one of the
things about being being a hater
regardless of what you're doing we all
have a Critic in us but it takes all the
pressure off you and it's you're allowed
to kind of like put the world down one
way or another yeah but that that
becomes there are people that just that
is how they identify they get off on it
and they find a community that's like
dollars all of us has to find find a
community somehow sometimes you find a
community in a group of people that are
have direct their their their hatred
towards someone or whatever
yes
um so so however you identify that's
going to be human and we all have some
of that in us but you want to feel part
of a tribe you're saying yeah but also
if that tribe's toxic but there are
people that are that are just generally
toxic now
I'm gonna and I'll tell you some lesson
I learned when you are that person when
you spend your time doing that and
really energized on trying to get
revenge or destroy or or be uh uh
addictive it will it will without a
doubt it will without a doubt that same
Destroyer comes back and gets you oh
yeah it's impossible not to that that is
the one thing I know I don't know much
but that's the one thing after 55 years
when I was a when I was an actor in in
uh theater school I was in a class with
amazing actors and I for a while had
some some kind of good victories in
class I I kind of had some breakthroughs
like auditions or something or just
scenes you do that that you know you did
something would you surprise yourself
you go wow man I'm learning how to be an
actor and so what I did after that was
old Bry decided I understood how to act
and I'm just gonna sit back and I'm just
gonna not do scenes for a while because
you know what dude I'm an actor now and
I'll let these other people try what I
enjoyed doing was being critical oh I
was at the top of the I'd sit at the top
row and I would look down on them and I
would criticize them and I did it to
myself sometimes I'd have a friend and
I'd like say a couple of shitty remarks
right now my teachers
one teacher was a an oscar-winning
director Milton casals directed Betty
Davis to a [ __ ] to an Oscar and a
number of other people and he had
everybody in that class everybody in
that class the Beverly Hills Playhouse
which was actually a Scientology thing I
never got involved in the Scientology
but she did but but it was it was it had
some amazing actors ever like people
would drop in from Neil Simon to Burt
Reynolds to Doris Roberts huge actors
who weren't designed for Reynolds over
slapped you I mean Anthony Hopkins came
in a couple times
okay so I would sit back and I would I
would criticize then I decided to do a
scene you know let me do a scene and wow
everybody you know now that I've arrived
let me show them how it's done yeah it's
like I took a couple wrestling learned
some wrestling moves from Dominic Cruz
in the green room and now I'm going to
try to wrestle with you what the [ __ ]
well that's what you you don't have
something to do but yeah in that case
I'm gonna [ __ ] you up but still like let
me let me let me let me let me wow the
world I get up and eat a dick I eat all
the dicks in front of 100 people who are
all really good actors I eat all the
dicks I'm doing [ __ ] I'm showcasing I'm
not listening to the person I don't know
what the [ __ ] I was you think you got it
teacher goes like this he goes wow man
you had all this stuff this what were
the circumstances yeah did you have that
going on and he's in front of Class B oh
yeah okay he goes wow and you're and
you're dancing and doing stuff over here
wow just showing us who you are not he
goes not good
not good
I mean rip me a new [ __ ] I was so
embarrassed I was so funny you could
tell where you're at you know what he
said to me he goes you know why right I
go yeah and he goes no that's not why at
all I've been watching you for the past
three months sit up there like the mayor
of this class sit up there like you know
something everybody doesn't because you
thought it was okay to take your foot
off the gas and you could be up there
and just be a Critic and what happened
when you got out here buddy
that same critic
came back and [ __ ] started critiquing
you in the scene and he was right but
you know what the difference is they'll
be I'm with you it's a great example at
least you risked it and put yourself out
there like my critics they've never done
any of that
or a lot of those haters have never done
any of that to take the like
you know what I'm saying like if Brian
count gives me a tip on something I'm
gonna listen yeah Brian's been in this
way longer than me you've made the same
mistakes I have I'm gonna listen to
Brian because you put yourself out there
yeah but if you've ever put yourself out
there and you're a Critic well then
part of social media and part of this
whole world is it's just everybody
it's really fun it's fun it could it's
fun to be a Critic and it's fun to
[ __ ] torture people probably you know
I I I've not done that but but it's it's
um what did I do one time I was talking
about somebody on a podcast and I forgot
that they were a person they were famous
comic nah I can't remember that but they
were famous and I was going a little bit
back sometimes you and I do that they're
like they're in the news or whatever
like we'll have fun with it but it's
really go bad you realize they're human
you realize that I've been there brother
they feel it I know and I [ __ ] and I
I went well you're famous you have a lot
of money so you must not care uh they
care yeah we all care you know I know
too many famous people who are like very
successful who get so much hate yeah if
it the only thing you can do is get the
[ __ ] away from it yeah yeah it's really
hard but I don't know I I think maybe
that's that's the maybe that's all part
of this maybe it's all part of the um
but maybe maybe also you wanna you wanna
just keep learning and you want to keep
uh sometimes by the way sometimes
critics are right sometimes critics have
some [ __ ] to say I've had plenty of
critics who who say stuff and I go [ __ ]
you're right I'm like I did Rogan one
time and this guy was like hey dude can
you not [ __ ] talk about all the books
you've read you're flexing for no reason
like it was so out of context and I was
like God he was right like I was a
[ __ ] sometimes donut there but then
sometimes you you know you do read those
books and it's nice to know I think I
might probably don't care about critics
exchange subject my boy keto George over
there [ __ ] George and you guys know
this story because I've said a thousand
times but I'm gonna say it a thousand
and one when I met keto George he called
in the king his thing he was about 403
43 000 pounds and he said I'm gonna get
down to 190 I said get to 190. I'll fly
you out here blah blah blah gets down to
190 a few months later you know God
willing to discipline he comes from
nothing in Chicago nothing he's in the
outskirts of Chicago taking care of his
mom and dad you know and he doesn't have
a lot of perspective back then you know
and he's fallen some hard times and
people have people in his life have died
from drugs and so he's around that
culture so I'm going to bring out him
show him a different culture he comes
out here he's an intern
[Music]
had no skill set then my boy Mike Neal
was like Hey I know how to edit produce
do all this I'm going to help you out
George spends time with George shout out
to Mike George lives with Mike Mike
downloads all his info he had a ton of
info into George George learns how to
edit produce make Clips do all these
things run his YouTube run his own
YouTube social media he learns the whole
gamut that's after a month
So the plan was just I'm out here a
month and be like all right dude hope
you have fun you know enjoy you know
hopefully enjoyed the thick boy
experience have a good day and the month
got done and Mike goes dude he's
actually learned a ton yeah you can do
stuff he goes yeah dude and this dude
worked so I'm interesting uh for uh
Georgia full-time gig here right so
George has a full-time gig start off
small payment now he's worked himself in
a straight up thick boy employee
then my boy Rich child goes hey we're
starting this fight program it's called
Alta where we're taking people I've
never fought before maybe they're doing
to lose weight who knows they're just
doing to face their fears they're going
to train for 20 weeks with one of the
top trainers uh in America and the end
of it if they want to they can take a
smoker MMA fight I go because you have
anybody else I think I would be
interested uh this guy keto George man
he's a Savage you wouldn't think here
this dude is a [ __ ] is so disciplined he
was 20 weeks man 7 A.M Monday through
Friday trust me if if it's not far he'll
be there I signed your keto George up
Paul George who just hired uh at the
time was like that sounds fun I want to
do it I know neither George has no fight
experience tall George's brother
starting for the Broncos he's athletic
so it's gonna be a little different for
him
so they train it's supposed to be 20
weeks for whatever reason with holidays
everything it gets pushed to over 30
weeks 7 A.M how many people do you start
with that train in that program George
like a little over 20 and how many
people were out there in four five
because remember seven a.m you can't
miss incredible
George by the way 9am training sucks
it's also kind of great but every day is
a beast so and they're getting their ass
kicked you know they don't have
experience and they're going with good
guys they're I show up to some of the
practice to help them out they're there
more than 30 weeks because they got
pushed then they had their fight this
last Friday at the Commerce City I told
both Georges uh before they find Fred I
went I've you know I made the joke here
if you lose you don't come back I'll see
clearly joking you idiots but I text him
I said I don't give a [ __ ] what happens
tonight what you guys are doing if you
make that walk and you step in that cage
that's all I care about the what you
guys are doing 99.9 of anybody who's
ever lived would never put this on the
line and enter that cage I said you've
already won dude I don't give a [ __ ]
what if you go in there and you get
knocked out
uh Ben astronaut style I don't care
that'd be terrible I don't care but just
just know if you can get through the
anxiety nerves which I know you guys are
dealing with right now I do not care
making that one for people so they get
in there we have highlights they get in
there dude both of them get in there
chin told me like he saw you walk in the
cage and he was like Georgie because he
was like obviously we're all scaredy I
was thinking about you guys all day Jim
was like Georgian you said George snow
was like
you made that walk and you got in a cage
and did an MMA fight that's more than
I've ever done so such a [ __ ] big
deal that is so that's terrifying like
you're [ __ ] doing an MMA fight I told
you it was real there were a lot of
people there yeah oh that was a real
Real Deals I've been in town Bobby green
was there yeah wow I was supposed to be
there was on tour unfortunately
dude I'd sent him messages before and
then I helped him with the game plan get
ready for it but then I was telling them
you know what they're doing is the
perspective and the the workout thing
the discipline it took to even get here
is unreal but
I know it's like day of the fight
there's nothing worse the nerves and
they've never competed we in any
Athletics at a high level I think I've
never done any footballs so how do you
feel now but B think about this kid
suburbs of Chicago small town yeah drugs
all this [ __ ] moms on you know he's
taking care of his mom she's getting you
know getting help from the government he
comes from that perspective
from that
to come in a thick boy
one of the best employees we have one of
the most loyal down Earth guys we have
30 weeks of training at 7 00 a.m this
isn't a New Year's resolution 30 and
then making me walk to the and then
fighting in a live mixed martial arts
cage
I saw the videos I mean that's you guys
are really banging people are trying to
[ __ ] kill each other oh yeah so so so
what do you how do you feel now like
when you woke up the next morning what's
your what's your perspective what do you
think what are you thinking right now
the day after once all the emotions and
everything came down I was just very
proud like yep so like you said not a
lot of people are willing to make that
walk there's almost nobody George
there's hundreds of people there
how many of them are going to walk to
the ring for a fist fight with five
cameras on them I I I'm not one of them
uh obviously the outcome wasn't what I
wanted but I listened to my corner I did
good like with what they were telling me
I was either a little bit too slow to
react to something what was going on in
your head when you first got in the cage
it was really just game time like the
lights were on I'm like I don't get
really nervous under a bunch of bright
lights I like I don't know once once I
was there I'm there do you want to keep
training of course keep training no more
fighting yeah I told both him in the
drawers no more fight I don't need you
fight that's stupid what's the point
here yeah it's good for them to test
themself this one time you know you can
do it you have the conies do it get out
a great experience
but but Brian think about this with
everything going on the world dude 400
pounds two years ago what what did
happen 190 what you weighing at 196. can
you remember
um what it was that made you just decide
you were tired of yourself like this
when it was 400 pounds I was 450 uh the
coronavirus just hit so we all got
locked down uh you had to leave the show
for a little bit so I was just stuck
with Brendan getting my inspiration and
just being at home I had nothing else to
do but watch these podcasts and hearing
Brendan talk with like Mike and Mike
catherwood and uh Josh Wolf when they
came in that really it just really like
it snapped something in my brain because
you said oh this could be me too yeah
Brendan at the time he was talking about
he was at his Max at 271 and in my brain
I'm like damn this guy I look up to
every day I watch every day it's got
bodies this morning going through the
the same [ __ ] I'm going through he's got
problem areas he doesn't like showing
his lower tummy
270 though remember when you beat
without a control now when you get into
the octagon and you were all like
self-conscious about yourself I was the
only amateur they just about took my
shirt off huh I'm the only amateur
Fighters how gangster is that yeah I'm
so proud of you I got to the ring I said
I didn't know I could take it off very
proud of you something about getting
naked like that trying your best you you
that that is worth that's so cool right
it's worth everything shout out to the
outdoor program and uh Rich child
foreign
I love that expression all the all the
fun is on the other side of fear and all
the fun is on the other side of fear and
and anybody out there and that's why I
should go to Jack Baggins haunted Museum
that's why you should go to the Zak
Bagans haunted Museum or or sign up for
military or do something that you are
afraid of and that you think doesn't
belong to you because it does belong to
you you can try it even if you don't do
it at least you're in it man sometimes
just getting stepping into the gym for
the first time and being like people are
you like it's so scary to walk into a
Muay Thai camera boxing gym or a jiu
jitsu school at first it's terrifying
and you don't know how you're going to
Georgia how do you feel during when like
when you're warming up like in the in
the back there I was definitely the
worst time I was feeling the nerves I
definitely was I was uh exploding a
little too much on too much on myths
like that like calm down yeah they were
like you don't want to waste energy yeah
they're like they would only let me warm
up for like a few minutes at a time and
my coach was like all right Jordan
that's my advice for both the George's
you know I woke up that morning I texted
him I said Hey listen the nerve's gonna
be insane before you get to the call to
the venue I said just to deal with the
nerves what I used to I used to
visualized the fight how I wanted it to
go and but it would start from you know
leaving your hotel room the stuff you
need to get you're talking you'll be so
detailed so you go through you visualize
every single thing from all right I'm
gonna wake up brush my teeth you're
picturing brushing your teeth it takes
you know over an hour just sitting there
visualizing I'm getting nervous yeah so
yeah I'm getting nervous right now yeah
so you're going through everything all
right you're gonna wake up more and
fight the nursery and be there so you
acknowledge the nerves because that's
normal you brush your teeth you do this
you can get a knock on the door from
your head coach at least you're born all
right show time you ready yep you have
all your things I would lay out my I
would I would Vis visualize in my fight
shorts and my walk out uniform I just
lay on the bed with all my gear on
mouthpiece in I'd have my gloves so you
were doing that so that you you so your
brain inoculate yourself to the stress
right yes but also just because when
then when you get there you've been
through it right it's kind of familiar
it's not this new territory takes the
fair out of it and then when you go on
the when you actually go through all
right taping my hands how you're gonna
feel doing that and them taping your
hands and then getting your octagon and
then when you visualize the fight you
put yourself in the worst case scenario
and getting out of it and winning and
then you'd always end the visual
visualization with you getting your hand
raised but I would go through every
scenario all right what if I go on there
he Clips me how am I gonna react how are
you gonna feel what are you gonna hear
like you literally got to go through all
that stuff yeah so you've been there
before but I would go through every
single scenario okay he takes you down
here so you're Guillotine how are you
gonna hand fight what are you going to
do what if he talks here what are you
doing what's your way out so in your
you've already gone over the process of
all right if you catch him in this I'm
gonna do this if he throws a kick I'm
gonna do this you can literally go
through the whole fight
hours I'd spend hours visualizing going
through every single scenario every
scenario all right you get knocked out I
visualize getting I got knocked out how
do you feel like when you get out what
are you gonna say to your dad what do
you do when you get to the hotel that's
how you're gonna feel how you gonna deal
with that so you go through every single
scenario yeah it's a lot anyone that
says MMA I never heard anybody talk
about that yeah anyone that says MMA is
like a solo athlete sport there's so
much teamwork and correct so many people
around you that are moving gears that
are helping you get there and George
that's why when you lost when you text
me like man I'm so sorry I'm gonna get
the [ __ ] out of I feel the same way
because there's so many people that put
so much energy and time into you you
feel like you're letting I can handle
the loss I'll figure it out trust me I
was more worried about my dad my brother
they got flights out there they can't
sleep at night my coach who sacrificed
time from his kids the strength he did
Lauren Lando the guy I've known for 10
years and here we are and you know I'm
this guy that I have his logo on my
shorts and he made all these sacrifices
to get here and so when you lose you're
just like oh dude I'm so sorry yeah and
they're like no everyone's like no so
when you told me sorry I'm like George
[ __ ] you I feel like everything is
easier after you go through that I
really do I feel like everything is
easier when you are a an MMA fighter and
you've walked you got into the cage and
you had a real fight with somebody and
you lose I feel like everything after
that is win or lose it's really not
about the results do you think that's
what I mean but don't you think
everything after that is not as
challenging I mean life throws a lot of
challenges your way but yeah it's just
different challenges like at least that
was a physical thing but yeah so like
you could die or you could no not really
I mean yeah you could get [ __ ] up
that's scariest thing that's why when I
would win like when I first started when
I get or at Mitchell I chucked around
the first round or Chris Dutcher Chase
Gormley uh the Gonzaga fight after every
single win I say I'm not religious after
every single win when I was in hurt as
soon as I got behind that the the big
drapes that they walk out of everyone
keep going they'd have to I'd have to
I'll catch up I would get on my hands
and knees and pray I'd like I can't
thank you enough that I'm not injured
yes oh my God oh my God with football
uh no
no because football I feel like
football's nowhere near scared it's not
as nowhere because you got a team you
have a whole team you're you're a tight
end or you're a full-back you're kind of
it was just different the stakes Doing
It Wrong they're high but you're worried
more about your knees fighting the the
stakes are so high yeah so with those
kind of team sports like you have a you
have a game next week you can't yeah
exactly you can't focus on exactly yeah
yeah and and I was younger back then
like when I was playing college ball and
even someone like injuries it was like
I'm I'm invisible like it's not gonna
happen like nobody thinks about that
like you know hey it's not let me ask
you this George I sent you because I
sent George cash at money I go hey I'm
sending some money some good amount of
money I go I want you and George to go
have a good dinner tonight and get some
drinks on me did you guys do anything
with it or did you save it and buy a
hooker I went out George he left early
to go hang out with his friends back in
Burbank makes sense so he didn't get to
go out but I went to Korean barbecue got
some Soju who'd you go with uh my team
[Music]
family's from Croatia so he walked out
and croak cop apparel I told him that's
offensive right that's offensive and
when we air the video I'm gonna edit
that out right well what if Brian
decided to do an MMA fight you yeah they
don't have a masters thing but I'm sure
we could find your opponent and then
what would I do what would I come out in
what would I wear you know
um
I make all your whole watches okay all
right did you ever see Bishop's walk out
that I handled myself got some good it
said Team shot remember it was like
Floyd Mayweather I had I had the whole
zip up from Echo yeah Echo go uh because
I demand all this stuff to go we don't
really do that how about we send you the
suits and we'll pay for you to design it
what do you want in the back of it good
enough yeah I put so much energy in that
because I take my mind off the fight
that's why I was always focused on how
that's interesting fashion took your mom
again yeah you are a gay man and that's
fine too and there's nothing wrong with
that yeah I'll uh I'll dollop now I'd
have to train I'll probably have to go
on trt I mean I would imagine well we're
gonna test you but sure go ahead
um yeah well you have shin guards on
because amateur yeah I got shin guards
daddy daddy
covers the psoriasis right no no
psoriasis well we'll see you and you're
pretty stressed on my phone you get
stressed also other things you got to
worry about I'm already nervous I'm
already nervous another thing about
worry about your teeth and design what
you think are straight which is
hilarious but let's go with that yeah
right not straight yeah still two more
trays still yellow two trays okay
getting them whitened sure get them
white and then manicured keep going okay
well then I'm gonna have beautiful teeth
do you have better teeth I mean congrats
in 20 days be ready my birthday January
26th I'm gonna have some beautiful teeth
I'm jealous well I need you to start
taking your time
never happening but here's the thing be
you know sign for this fight and your
tricklets do just beautifully put a lot
of time in yeah someone's gonna punch
you in the [ __ ] mouth which I want
but I got my mouth guard yeah yeah sure
I'm a cobra my head never stops moving
Fair Point now let's not put me in there
with somebody who's young and very
athletic let's get me in there with no
we'll see with a lot of people out there
so we'll see yeah you I do all your
merch game yeah I have so many fans I'm
literally nervous about what do you have
fans oh just a visualization thing I'm
nervous going through that I'm nervous
thinking about it I never forget those
days I'd be at MGM Grand waking up at 6
a.m 5 a.m can't sleep and you're just
sitting there and I used to work with
these coaches that have you do that and
I'm just sitting there trying to breathe
and and then you just pitch yourself
getting kicked in the face knocked down
like oh God I gotta get out of this
headset I get this headspace I gotta
[ __ ] get out of this man I laid out
all my uh gear like Deion Sanders Prime
Time on the ground like I said it all
out like I was about to wear it that's
what I would do I would wear it George I
would wear and I'd wear my gloves from
the last fight I would save people like
oh to it for you know to autograph like
no no I would say so I could put those
on because they're tight I'd wear them I
put everything on I just lay there so I
could feel I might shave my body down
and come out with my body paint that'd
be cool yep oh no what you should do is
uh we you could do all that and then
like the old school boxes would write a
sponsor we'll have them pay to write on
your back that's right on my back and my
tummy yeah like wrinkles.com yup
ranks.com or your only fans and Mutt and
nobody debut your money no we put your
only fans account on your back we draw
it in my only fans I I feel like I'll
starve I don't think anybody is going to
tune into the only fans well there's
only one way to find out but also and
then on your butt like old school days
you put condom Depot there's that my my
we used to do that but my friend's wife
was into Old Men she would watch porn
with old dudes having sex how old like
they had gray hair and they were in they
were 70 75. she was into that and what's
that called kind of important I guess
it's guilf Grandpa I'd like to [ __ ] porn
and she was into that I guess there are
women out there if I discovered my girls
in that I'd be disgusted with her yeah
not me I'd be like thank God I have I
have uh there's there's hope for me well
no you you we don't need to know your
girls into guilf porn because she
married it that's very true and I say to
her a lot all [ __ ] aside I look at
her and go uh the other day I was like
how the [ __ ] I looked at my I saw a
picture of myself and I was like that's
a bad angle and she goes no that's what
you look like and I was like
how are you attracted to me like I I you
go you're disgusting I'm disgusting dude
how about you'll love this how it's
being important how about in Vegas was
the AVN Awards yeah and all the porno
stars were staying at our hotel oh I was
like I know her I know I know her and I
was like man I wish I had the trading
card I monograph it like a UFC fan but
hey could you just sign them right there
yeah across the tips you recognize some
of them oh I recognize some and then
there's this large black gentleman he's
about six seven
and he's with a short short white girl
and Jay goes is there basketball in La
I'm like what because Jay doesn't watch
porn like I do what because look at that
giant guy go
oh no no no no no no that's Derek from
black.com I've seen his work Derek and
Jay goes you don't play basketball I go
awesome he doesn't but he's dunking
bring him up hey hey he's done Derek
he's dunking those and he's nuts in her
small butthole and I've seen it he's got
a piece and he he slams it home
I thought no way
I don't know there's a Derek Dozer on
black.com dude and Jay goes is the NBA
antenna no no but they both okay there
he is Derek's got a piece on him Derek's
got an absolute hunk of a t cable on
here yeah I've seen all his work that is
gigantic I've seen all his work is he
that's not him though right this is him
right yeah that's him dude oh it's Derek
well this dick is is his dick is as
large as I am
that might be Anton or Antoine I think
pipe dream
Lord have mercy Derek Dozer
okay well either way I'm impressed very
well right yeah either way I recognize
them I'm ashamed of myself and Jay
thought he was a NBA basketball player
and I said no no no no no no yeah but he
slams it home okay
all right Ducks nuts and butts I'm
impressed you know this yeah those guys
oh I'm impressed director Derek Dozer
all right I'm impressed also oh that's
the guy that's who you've seen his work
no right there bring him up next to that
blonde girl right there here no go down
my dick to the left to left to left to
left right there bring that up we can't
show any of this on screen by the way no
the other guy buddy the other guy which
one you said to the left right there no
go to the right go to the right go to
the right no to the right right there
that's who you saw correct
I've decided and that was the girl
[ __ ] man
hazer Suds and if I was a gal I'd be way
more into that guy than me I know that's
a shirt that's a shot and most are and
most are
I wouldn't even know if my car my girl
with a guy like that I wouldn't even
what am I going to say how dare you
you're more you're not in a medium and
wrinkled
this guy's way bigger that guy has the
same hairline as you but look at his
wiener he's way bigger than dirt Dozer
yeah that's a large bigger wiener yeah
not size no that's a crazy week Larry's
direct recognize Derek is from his
height these guys boy they they um the
women are beautiful too they're very
very attractive
those guys are they're busy Jack Slayer
and a guy named pressure the other guy's
name is pressure plugs a lot of pressure
and Ella Reese was the lucky uh winner
point is I saw them okay yeah no no I'm
sure it must have been and I'm
autographed my hoodie quite the scene
did you get recognized by any of them
uh by the big black guys no
okay buying the other ladies no only
gotta get recognized by the lead singer
of um
the lead singer of Imagine Dragons oh
really we're on the same flight together
and he was with his gorgeous he's
awesome he's with uh oh Mika Kelly now
and I saw her of course I recognize her
I'm like oh I go where do I know her
from and then I he has shades on because
we're flying on the same plane rounds
great guy and he loves guys goes are you
Brandon that's me my man how do I know
he's like uh Dan uh Imagine Dragons the
band oh [ __ ]
he's a Vegas kid stud whoa look at this
no he's a big fella man he's a muscular
fella
look at his body I'm sure he doesn't get
girls at all I'm sure girls don't like
him at all you know who Minka Kelly is
no insanely bring up Mika Kelly look at
him look at his bird too build yeah he
just got a divorce
[ __ ] awesome yeah he lives in L.A now
but uh he's a Vegas boy he's gonna do a
show and then we're gonna meet up for
drinks at the at a hotel and then I got
done too much Jesus she's uh she's
what's the word yeah gorgeous yeah I
think she used to date Derek Jeter okay
what does she do she's just hot actress
she's actress yeah okay and obviously
not from this planet so that's cool she
is not from this planet and that is cool
well she did date Trevor Noah I remember
that all right well so you know she's a
high she did she dates high value males
quote unquote
okay yep
all right well yeah
to you sir for being on top of the world
stayed a lot of guys John Mayer Derek
cheater now let's say you know their net
worth or what they did for work dirt
dude be the last guy you pick for her
that is correct he looks like [ __ ] he's
getting older and uh but I told you I
was with him in Las Vegas
and it was Mark Wahlberg it was uh
I was there for I believe the Manny
Pacquiao fight when he fought
um kodo I believe that's what it was
okay either way
but uh I tell you I have never seen and
Derek Jeter was I think it was last year
playing or something I have never seen
women
uh react to a man that way was your dick
dripping I'm not as big a baseball fan I
know he is telling you about Dick drip a
little no I didn't get any leakage but
no dick drip I I've never seen that in
my life which is women Will Ferrell as
famous he was Mark wall didn't matter
they were like I did I think I told you
that we were all they were at a
different table I was over at this table
now and then they were over here at the
same restaurant I was no no we all we
were we went to an event yeah I think we
went to the fight together and then like
I was walking with them right
and then
um when we went to the nightclub they
were over here Bubba I'm telling you the
women that were being brought up to
Derek Jeter like in groups to me known
for it I was like that's the craziest
[ __ ] when you're captain of the New York
Yankees that's one of the benefits
get your mind right I was I was standing
next to him and um
a woman came up she was working at the
uh venue and she had a wedding ring big
wedding Big Time beautiful gorgeous
gorgeous and she said you don't remember
me I met you and she was talking to him
she was so smitten he's got no game
oh look at it doesn't have to no no but
he's just listening to her and you could
see that she was like even though she
was wearing this big rock she was just
in love with a guy like that's a weird
thing I I've seen that with with Messier
Mark Messier he's Captain the Rangers
yeah so that with him and I saw that
with uh that's the only time I've ever
seen where I went oh oh There are some
guys that can have sex with all the
girls right now it doesn't matter
obviously like yeah you like the month
of October like yeah they call me Mr uh
they call me Mr October are you Reggie
Jackson no I'm not that old [ __ ] I'm the
new Rich
differences the captain of the Yankees
and you're right yeah he's clutch yeah
I'm not afraid to admit it dude are you
watching any football
do you watch any football you know what
the thing is this this the fish have
taken over my life yesterday I was busy
cleaning the tank you got to be joking I
didn't see an ounce of football you got
all the red zone at night I saw nothing
yesterday that's amazing that you're
that into because I just got the puffer
fish and I gotta take care of them and
now here's the thing about puffer
fishing I did for my son he's like Dad
can you please get him like they're cute
as [ __ ] I'll give you that so I got him
here's the problem they go date live
shrimp like okay well wait wait the
puffer fish do yeah they only like live
Crustaceans it's a problem dude do you
have to now breathe shrimp
dude so I go [ __ ] you and your dumb fish
I know I'm mad at myself this is the
third podcast we've talked about [ __ ]
fish but puffer fish are cool I get it
dude send me the video on the puffer
fish if I get one more video of a fish
that you're now buying
wait wait now did I put one on layaway a
flower head yeah I did what's a flower
head the most aggressive cichlid out
there it's a cichlid cichlid now you
gotta get now they had a full grown one
but the uh the flowerhorn flowerhorn you
have a big I'm gonna need you more
careful look how dope he is dude he's
aggressive uh aggressive what's that
does he have a giant brain what the [ __ ]
is with that big bulb on his head
Megamind he's got Megamind she got the
big brain on is that how big he is for
Real is that how big they get no oh oh
oh no no that's fake no okay but like
this look full grown probably like this
be
with a giant brain now now here's the
thing you you that's fake is that is
that chat gbt does he have like
artificial intelligence in his head what
the [ __ ] is going on here this is crazy
bro no I do not do I do I buy him do I
get extra channels my TV yeah I do from
the antenna that's crazy he but he's
Uber aggressive of course so you got to
be careful because the reason I'm
waiting on this juvenile because he has
the white ick you know what white dick
is the viewers get a piece of paper so
they can write this down it's the flu
for fish they recover after five they
get the flu it's called White ick it's a
prop white very contagious you ignoring
me with all your because I'm an expert
no very contagious so so the the the
flowerhorn I wanted had the white egg
wait I got that feeling I gotta wait
five days it's kissing him let's just
take a little nibble trying to see the
size difference they're huge they're big
I have Oscars too Oscars get a foot long
dude they say it bites like a piranha
now watch what happens when he tries to
catch this fish probably bite them they
bite like a piranha flower problems are
sick the one they had that I was going
to buy but they're like do you have fish
his same size and go no they're all
juveniles and go oh he'll eat them all
and kill them
the one they had in the tank he's by
himself who's it by himself they go oh
why walk up to the tank I'm like why
like just walk up I walk up he's ramming
the tank with his big nut sack on his
head boom boom he's fantastic
oh yeah wanted to fight what the [ __ ]
yeah that fish is aggressive toward a
toward a giant man yeah how cool is that
so I got his uh his son I got the baby
how to treat ick
oh don't let your fish get the ick
the white square and salt to the water
ADD medication to the water remove any
carbon in the filter before beginning
any treatment as it will render the
medication useless daddy always has them
I already have the medication just in
case my fish get it
white spot but here's the problem be
back to the puffer fish they want life
Crustaceans because they have those
beaks those teeth yeah they don't want
soft food because it helps because you
can't think of the dentist it cleans the
teeth and make sure they don't like show
them longer
so he goes hey man the puff fish about
we've only been feeding live shrimp well
that's not happening can I give them the
Frozen tribulas you can try they're
pretty picky that's why I wake up I drop
in the the frozen shrimp these little
bastards just watch it like hey [ __ ]
where's the real deal they want real
stuff so after I leave here I can go buy
real shrimp you gotta buy real shrimp
it's exhausting now you're gonna have to
make a lot of you have to make a lot of
trips you have to go there every day to
get live shrimp until I buy another tank
and start raising shrimp
I made a mistake what kind of shrimp are
they they're little Krill shrimp
see you got to feed them Krill you gotta
fly you gotta raise them so now you're
gonna have five tanks in the house four
well I'll have five in March I'm in Salt
one in March oh and the guy from tanks
reached out to me the head host reached
out to me yep awesome so let's get you a
tank he's from tanks tanks huge show
Tanked tanked tanked massive show that's
a big shot it's off here now for 15
Seasons really you got everything wrong
don't you I mean just your name tanks
taint might watch the show my
brother-in-law and my nephew are like he
said Nebuchadnezzar or something like
Peter Meyer
so hard yeah that's funny and all soccer
fans were like what the [ __ ] no no wait
what were we talking about
well we don't know their name either
that's the best part what are we talking
we didn't say [ __ ] no messy and [ __ ]
yeah
and Ronaldo outside that you and me
don't know and the other guy oh I don't
know and the French is American the
French guy
all right wait what about um wait we
were talking about something else before
we got into this [ __ ] point is I re I'm
I'm I'm Bubba Gump I raise shrimp now
bring us what do you got Tim bring us to
talk about something awesome current
events
so he's apparently doing better I know
he actually tweeted or posted a picture
too yeah
how about how about Buffalo Bills return
the first kickoff that's incredible yeah
the power of sports here's the thing you
motivate Pros to get going baba I I
would put a lot of money on the bills
winning at all is that they have a
reason to go yeah
from critical condition to now like
responsive and he's actually awakened
yeah do we think he'll play again we
don't not this year not this year I bet
eventually he does not this year
I hope so man hey God is good give it up
good brother God is good
God is good uh and also people most
most people want the uh the person that
gave the CPR to tomorrow or
do you want him to be like in the Hall
of Fame right yes yes in the Hall of
Fame and uh this is the guy right hold
on one second your boy your boy uh okay
tomorrow Hamlin's yeah
this guy Denny Kellington is what he's
trained for God bless I guess he was
giving CPR for a long time six minutes
yeah don't stop you did not stop can't
stop won't stop can't stop won't stop we
can't have one of the touchdown balls
too yeah hey give them money oh yeah hey
bills give them
pays money pay his mortgage off yeah buy
his house off buy his house off he would
never do this but the Bill's Mafia is so
rabid they could start a GoFundMe for
him and he could pay his house off
guaranteed hey Bill's Mafia do that yeah
that'd be great yeah do that he deserves
it yeah for sure
um
what's your boy uh Aaron Rodgers
got knocked out
yeah I know Denver won last yesterday
were you excited about that no I hate
them
why because they're so bad
but you know I'm I'm your boy your boy
from the Seahawks is now their
quarterback my boy he's ruined the
program what do you mean you pay him too
much [ __ ] money now he's keep
forgetting there's one problem there's
one problem happy he's no good
come on what happened that's from Happy
Gilmore just a messed up a messed up
offensive scheme I don't know no he's
just not playing well he's just he's not
he's not himself is it because he's
throwing interceptions then he has uh he
has more basketball he's not a thing
when they get when they get this crazy
contract a lot of times it's the
guarantee money if you look at all the
top guys that are guarantee money they
kind of suck isn't that weird yep you
know what's worse than football baseball
when those boys get those guaranteed
contracts Yep they're just like thank
you I know oh no another strikeout yep
you got because you got so much to
manage you got the view you get to go
but is it it's complicated right because
you want the players to get money but
then when they do get money they're not
as good but then you look at Hamlin it's
like he's not set so you can see why
players want guaranteed money the the
Enemy at the the irony is the Enemy at
the door is comfort and success
certainty and comfort certainty and
comfort you got to be a little bit
[ __ ] uncomfortable maybe Spotify
comes they're not but Spotify account
said hey we'll give you 500 where do I
sign
wait wait wait what is that sorry
Spotify says where do I sign what do I
I'll sign what do you want we'll give
you five dollars five dollars no you'd
be so disappointed yeah but if they came
to us and gave us 500 minutes I'm doing
it right now do it right now but but how
often would you do the show would you
still do it twice a week
look dude if they if 500 million dollars
they said you have to you have to poison
Brennan's [ __ ] one of his many drinks
it's gonna take a long time just put
this wear a ring I would be like that's
[ __ ] outrageous how much like
and you would die but do you but do you
think of what spot Spotify said this hey
we can give you 500 mil we don't give a
[ __ ] do the show once a week or five
times a week it's up to you guys do you
think we continue to do it as many times
as we do take a book yeah I think we do
I think you and I would love it yeah me
too I mean what I mean I don't know
that's a good question well I don't do
this I mean yeah the money's great but
that's not what we started it no no we
never made it no I never expected to
make money yeah I expect it to uh try to
sell tickets but I never yeah
yeah that's it I never started for my I
got to get back also what else would you
do be what else would you you know what
I'm saying like if you didn't have this
what would you do just sit around your
Mansion all day in your underwear no I'd
lose my mind I'll probably start a
haunted mansion like that what would I
do you know what I would do to be out
you want to really know what I would do
I'm not really sure it's gonna be so
stupid and boring I I know you're right
I'm gonna write I'm gonna write books no
I'll give you three guesses travel the
world nope uh okay I get three guesses I
really think I would do this
think about what I would do invest in
your boxing your wrestling career yes
yeah okay
no you wouldn't no you wouldn't because
you can't pay for that what do you mean
I would train all the time you'd have
trained 24 7. so what I can do that
a trainer you would want I'm telling you
wouldn't want to do that because it's
going to take 10 years minimum so how
old are you right now black belt 10
years minimum hey do you know how fast I
pick up on [ __ ] oh it doesn't matter we
haven't tussled since I had my first
first lesson but let's go through this
you have 500 million dollars yeah and
you think black belts are the key yeah
10 years minimum wrestling and I'm doing
some rest that's ten years minimum
forget that so so you know you got the
black belt in 10 years 10 years BJ Penn
no he got in five first of all you got
to be more accurate number two bring
that up number two number two you [ __ ]
I'll get my black belt in five years oh
you could buy one for sure
no no no oh John's definitely not giving
you a black belt John is giving me my
black belt oh three years BJ gun three
yeah bro yeah so I'll give myself five
because they I'm pretty smart and I pick
up on [ __ ] and as my tennis coach said
Brian's sponge so [ __ ] you I don't like
your attitude get your [ __ ] hand out
of my face you know what your test coach
says that right keep your hand down
your sponge pay me
pay me Wayne McCullough too my boxing oh
all day hey pay me hey Brian you should
Spar pay me
hey pay me and you're stupid enough to
do it dude I'm telling you right now hey
you stupid I'm telling you right look at
me
I'm telling you right now you're stupid
dude
I'm a [ __ ] dominant Cruise disciple
now okay you let me just move this if
you're feeling froggy
not much dude hey all right you ready
for this why you're a grown man with
kids right yeah look at me you stupid
that offend you
hey
you're out of your [ __ ] mind oh what
happened you plants bro leave that
it's not that bang bang that's where it
comes no I'm covered by the mic that's
where it comes right it's double double
tap back now your face your nose is even
flatter right well uh Dominic didn't
teach you any of this what teach me what
dude teach me [ __ ] what oh
see push it this way and now where am I
now you're now we got some problems
right if I get up oh we got some
problems all right sunshine hey if I get
up I'm gonna yank those Invisalign out
and you're not gonna have a good day
right got a new sweater on so I want to
say I know you do I'm trying to be cool
because you're gonna start sweating I
know but you you got to watch your tone
you're stupid let's go to current events
right now before I get [ __ ] don't say
it again don't say it again because that
part also is being conditioned
and I will ride your [ __ ] body with
my shin stupid
I don't know what that is that's when I
start getting
[ __ ] when I start throwing different
chain wrestling I go
that was five different gears
you know what happened if you got 250
million dollars can you split it well
you'd probably get 100 million right
because sure I do most leg work but so
uh if you got let's say 10 million
dollars out of the 500 hey bro I'm just
kidding you know what the [ __ ] are you
negotiating here what do you mean so if
you got five how do you get all the
money okay so we got how did that happen
if I give you fifty thousand dollars
after the 500 million we made bro after
your cut bro we wait I don't think you
would dedicate your life to jiu jitsu
yes that's what makes me laugh you think
you would dedicate your life to Jujitsu
I get bored wouldn't I those days I have
a lot I have a key for different days I
go key no key no you're instructed like
very good very good 700 thank you sir it
was like Rashad uh who who remember
Rashad who's uh Tony uh what the [ __ ] is
his name Jesus Christ I know Rashad who
you're talking about was that box yeah
and he was uh he was uh Tony um
Jeffries no the who's the MMA fighter oh
my God
Ferguson's striking coach and I said
that shot I go man Teach Me How to
because Wayne had gone to Vegas so I was
like so I was asking him how to slip and
all that and why are we trying and
finally he's teaching me and he goes
like this he just stops he goes
Brian you all this [ __ ]
like in other words I can't he goes
you're old as [ __ ] he goes I mean I if
you really want to work we could do it
sometime and I was like oh man I was
like damn he's like manual as [ __ ] he's
exhausted even talking to me about it
yeah what else got Jen okay so this is
super cool he's a friend of the show a
friend of all of us jelly roll has the
number one uh country radio song amazing
in the world right now General Penn's
emotional message the fans have to earn
his first number one at country radio I
do this for y'all shout out man how
amazing is that dude it's such a huge
accomplishment so talented man yeah I
love that dude son of a sinner great
song Too one of my favorite songs wow so
who did he beat out like like everybody
everyone yes Nate like more I don't know
everyone yeah damn a Morgan Wallen has
different records but as far as country
radio right now billboard number one son
of a sinner
I have heard it and co-written by Ernest
who's uh also amazing as well it's a
great song I'm gonna listen to that one
on the way home
when I go to work out in the rain I
don't take time off
I don't take out how long have you guys
watched the The Joe Rogan podcast with I
post this I said I've watched this over
10 times I couldn't get off it when
because you know how Rogan did yeah so
him and Dave port and I really don't
know each other and Dave was talking
about how uh Tommy fear is not a real
boxer and Rogue knows bring him up and
he's talking to her and he'll shut the
[ __ ] up shut the [ __ ] up he goes you're
[ __ ] high you told me he's a real
boxer and then Dave's just like not to
me
no it was a great podcast yeah
is not a real boxing no chance Rogan
reactor of course the real box
professional boxer is your world
champion no maybe he is he is he he's
not uh poor never played no replied no I
saw Tommy Fury box he's not a boxer to
which Rogue said well he's definitely a
boxer porno interjected well he puts on
gloves
porno is funny dude yeah he's definitely
a box but uh is he a boxer like his
brother no well of course not listen I
see what uh Dave is saying but it's
tough when you're not you have no
background in fighting and then you're
calling a guy who actually risks it and
does fight you should call him not a
boxer you can say he's not a skilled
boxer you can say he does Jake Paul beat
his ass knocks him on two rounds oh
really 100 it's just easy work for Jake
really because Tommy just doesn't have
the experience just not as good uh
they're about the same experience I
think six or seven fights right but it's
just Tommy doesn't want that uh it
sounds like they're gonna do it but okay
you know he's backed out twice now so
now would Tommy's would Tommy have his
brother they can't come to the States oh
but his brother would probably coach him
I don't know the last one he didn't
something was up but it sounded like the
family told him not to take it yeah it'd
be a bad fight for Tommy yeah but just
because Jake can beam doesn't mean
Tommy's not a boxer yeah I think Rogan's
point was it's disrespectful because
Dave has no background because Dave was
talking about how Justin Gates you tend
to beat him up and he doesn't know who
he is and Brogan's like what's the most
violent man in the UFC he's like holy
[ __ ] you think he's like beat up a guy
from the streets everyone was like no
but I'd watch your p's and q's around
him and Dave was like you know I get
that and he goes but Sandy can beat up
me doesn't say much he's like your
producer could beat me up he goes I've
never been in a fight
he's like okay so you can beat my ass
you're a professional I've never been in
a fight yeah
yeah I mean yes you would definitely not
want to fight Justin Gage no by the way
by the way you don't want to fight just
in case you if you've been fighting no
one of the cool things about Dominic
Cruz Dominic Cruz was talking about how
he's trained his whole life one of the
grades and he was talking about like he
he he knows Jon Jones and Jon Jones is
joking around one time or kind of first
time he ever met him John goes come on
man you know just kidding around like
that Dominic was like get the [ __ ] away
from me I'm not gonna even pretend to
spar with you no like like they're just
a physics thing some dudes are you know
doesn't matter you're very I think when
you're a dominant Cruz or somebody and
you're you fight at 135 you're more
aware of your limitations and also your
skill set than anybody else especially
people who don't fight well I mean Jon
Jones the greatest of all time he's 200
[ __ ] yeah yeah exactly yeah you know
you'd be a brain surgeon figure that no
but I mean I think the more you fight
the more aware you are of your own
limitations that's what it is uh we kind
of talked about the sunshop show but um
I think it's worth mentioning here so
Jamie Foxx so DL Hughley made a post
about the whole Dana White slapping his
wife incident I'm not I'm not sure we
talked about on fighting the kid but did
we or no yeah I talked about it with uh
with uh
um oh Steve Brent with Steve yeah okay
so this is what D.L Hughley put out on
his Instagram Bobby Brown or Antonio
Brown did what Dana did what Chris Brown
did but worse and so did Bobby and
Antonio has some issues but um I mean
terrible examples he should pick three
guys that didn't happen uh the media
wouldn't stop talking about what can
Brown do for you be white hashtag team
deal and then uh so Jamie Foxx uh
replied some like preach something like
that [ __ ] pretty and I I was saying
the chin on top I don't think it's the
black white thing I think it's a success
thing Dana's so successful that's why
it's not getting picked up well also Dan
is not you can't cancel Dana because
it's his company that's a success thing
it's not his company yeah it's not his
company right it's it's all right but
the deal hopefully thing was more like a
white it's already a black thing it's
not a white and black thing it's a
success thing yeah isn't it also that
his like they both kind of took
ownership she hit him first I don't
think I don't think it has anything to
do with it I literally think this shows
you how powerful Dana White is because
people go it got lost in the in the in
the new cycle like no no in order for it
to get lost it would have to come out it
didn't come out that's how powerful he
is they just squashed it and pushed the
slap League a week everyone's like okay
yeah so they never canceled that slap
League it just got postponed
crazy yeah crazy crazy yeah
uh I mean deals right to the point where
if it was somebody else it'd get way
more coverage like if Skip Bayless came
out us he'd lose his job 100 yeah but
remember like the the there's a bunch of
stuff that was happening in the news
cycle at that time too so that
contributed to it there's more things to
focus on like the Hamlet situations more
time let me see this Skip Bayless tweet
about it so I mean this is like kind of
what you guys talked about last week
with uh Steve Byrne Skip Bayless that's
what he's supposed to do yes there's the
ratings shot up by 57 after that there
you go baby confrontations
the search gave the show 227 total
viewers of the day that so the brass is
happy
yeah I mean that's that's what skip does
though that's skipping Stephen A Smith
yeah they give you hot Texas like I like
Stephen A Smith I've always liked him I
think he's you know I don't like him
when he does MMA no I like him
he talks football uh yeah I like going
to talk sports yeah yeah not MMA and I
like yeah I like certain takes I don't
like his take uh his take on dating was
such a [ __ ] move I didn't know such a
[ __ ] he's like you know I spoke to him
he's a very good friend I hope he
figures it out like but you've been
breaking freaking Kyrie Irving or over
the cold for the past two months too
over that [ __ ] these these people Kyrie
Irving do the anti-smite thing he liked
the movie
he's talking about the movie for for two
months that's uh they're both two
different things aren't they though but
I'm saying if that if your goal if your
job is to comment on on Sports Dana is a
sports figure and just because you have
a personal relationship with them as a
journalist which he is through and
through your job especially just because
the guy works on your network to go mom
on it it's like okay you're compromised
100 and compromised ESPN's compromised
I haven't reported on in any facet
that's compromise this is news
no matter how your friend or not it's
news
to not say a word line or just give them
supports like oh that's interesting
that's how powerful Dane is
yeah it's true we didn't see it pop up
in as many places as it should have
you'll see it on MMA fighting with your
hawani Luke Thomas and Brian Campbell
talk about it I talked about a little
bit I'll set that nowhere nothing yeah
ESPN one of their head reports came out
said we were told not to say anything
what your own you're owned by Disney
well and the TMZ piece was just very
like weird and it's very close so easy
yeah yeah it just shows you how powerful
he is
so this is actually okay this is a a
headline's crazy but it's cool that Bam
Margera he's going through a lot of
stuff drug abuse and all that stuff
um wasn't a part of the jackass you know
the most recent film that they had
because he was on right Stevo's podcast
recently and they kind of like hashed it
out and Margera admitted that he was
pronounced dead after suffering
suffering five seizures and pneumonia in
December what are the seizures from
just
doing too much
but he was on Stevo's podcast ever for a
while they were just like not together
right yeah they're like We're Not Gonna
Keep yeah
until you get sober
so yeah that's good yeah I used to love
bam I still liked him but you know he
was on top of the world for a while yeah
as Sean MTV awesome cars too yeah
I just saw this recently from the fight
Mafia this is a guess is a picture from
this the is that a real set of Connor
apparently the set of uh the Roadhouse
with Jake Gyllenhaal but but Connor
posted a pic of him in the gym his back
is Jack he's so jacked right now Jesus
Christ he looks but he look right here
he looks gigantic
yeah he does yeah that is a that is a
lot of chicken breast
and weight lifting
a lot of that it looks great oh yes this
is the last one I just saw this I don't
know how he he saw this things he's into
things so this girl this is your boy
adam22 talking to a girl I guess she's
like a very famous porn star I don't
know her personally
but uh here I'll just play it for you
Scarlet Scandal what is the most that's
Adam's wife right there
oh this is that the ABN I think her
name's plus Scarlet scandal
oh the girl that fisted the black girl
yeah okay analyst thing you've ever done
oh my God sorry
but I [ __ ] him what she saw him Oscar
De La Hoya
and maybe chase him around his apartment
go fishing for it yeah it was nuts
he walks away what is the most Scandal
but she didn't say uh
oscar but I [ __ ] him what she does say
it but they bleeped out or not bleeped
up they they muted it
Oscar's like God yeah and he put on my
clothes and made me chase him around his
apartment we had to make it chase him
around like a bunny hey hey
go crazy for it yeah it was nuts he's in
this he's in a weird ship but like
Charlotte Scandal what is the most
scandalous oh my God sorry
oh yeah like why go bad on that why go
bad on on somebody it's just like what's
the craziest thing you've ever done and
by the way it's not bad if you like that
yeah but it's embarrassing it is
embarrassing yeah it's where he's into
that I mean not even weird if that's
what he's into no he's into it I'm just
saying it's like
so so just for the record Oscar de la
Hoyas is one of the greatest hits in one
of the hardest Sports and and I just I
hate this is what I hate about [ __ ]
social media personally it's just Oscar
went out Dana though so I think this is
kind of people you know didn't have so
much support yeah he went super and him
and Dana were cool I thought because he
reached out to Dana to like make amends
though but as soon as this the scam
yeah oh Oscar went after him yes right
away so once you do that I see people
start coming for you yeah
um he played the same game sort of if
you play the play the game yeah
I don't know Oscar freak I don't think
anything I don't think anything good
comes from any of that stuff
the reason we brought it up because yeah
no no I'm not saying you shouldn't have
brought it up I'm glad yeah
just for whatever reason it bombs me I
don't give a [ __ ] yeah I mean it's not
it's not like you did anything bad I
agree yeah
um but it's like what'd you say George
Brian said it bums me out there
yeah you know no I just don't want to
freaked I don't like that he's he's got
things that he likes whatever it is if
that's true and I just don't like them
apparently she's like a famous yeah it's
not just it's like it's like um people
are into weird [ __ ] and I just don't
like when it's brought out in the Public
Square like that you know just like it's
like he's I think he's such a great
boxer and exhibited so much courage and
I don't know and he's got problems maybe
he has an issue with drugs I'm a
different guy now though yeah these
aren't the Box charts yeah he talks a
lot of [ __ ] and does his thing yeah yeah
like he's been in the news for the wrong
reasons
it's probably the least there are
already pictures of him and that that's
been out for Hudson yeah yeah I think
he's currently he's fighting he's a
weird dude yeah he's weird I mean maybe
not I mean the girl's so hot she's like
he put on these stockings and do your
thing up [ __ ] girl tequila capture
inside his ass jokes I don't think he
was joking he's like whatever it takes
just figure this out you want to put
some gloves give me them gloves it was
10 ounces whatever you want whatever if
they're so hot dress up like a [ __ ]
bunny or whatever the hell they want I'm
gonna be you know what's important it's
important because I'm in Tampa next week
Thursday or sorry Friday Saturday only
Tampa Florida yeah Tampa improv's great
oh that's great Friday Saturday only the
Springfield Missouri February 3rd and
fourth yeah the Blue Room Springfield
Missouri February third and fourth
Naples you were just there be sep uh
February 16th and 18th Bakersfield's one
night only uh February 23rd Baker Fields
California and then Breya right now just
March 4th I have a companion I think on
the third so Brea California two shows
only as of right now March 4th if that
bad boy will sell out so get your teeth
from one night only Brea Improv
California's March 4th but right now
Tampa you're up next week Tampa Florida
Friday Saturday only Tampa get you
something
come get some uh Fort Wayne Indiana
first of all San Diego thanks for coming
out everybody my trout Comedy Club what
a great club and uh you guys were all
amazing Fort Wayne Indiana Summit Comedy
Club I got two nights Friday Saturday
January 13th January 14. that's this
coming Friday Saturday come get some
still tickets left uh Dania Florida
January 19 2021 come get some of that
that's going to be fun and then I got
Edmonton Alberta the comic strip
February 23 24 25. I'll see you there
all right kids we love you thanks tuning
in we're out yeah